we learn how to use free tools to
understand what people will search when
searching for your solution now let's
think about the places either virtual or
physical that potential customers will
be exposed to your business these places
are the paths to get your product to
your customer
we call them distribution channels for
coca-cola a distribution channel can be
a grocery store or a restaurant usually
for consumer packaged goods the
distribution channel is wholesale retail
distributors ecommerce websites things
like that now for your app it'll
probably be one of the app stores or a
website or even a creative partnership
you can think of so on that note let's
talk about partnerships